[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof button you must stop
doing this now
what do you want me to do
I don't know but uh I guess you can't
stop the trainer it's got full steam now
this this is a runaway train at this
stage oh I was elected like that the
other way other day but that was us
number two that was number two yeah
still waiting number one is not there
yeah let's open with a word of Prayer
our heavenly father
thank you for giving us the energy
to have come thus far
not missing one episode
gee we need you
to guide us in this one again with the
Holy Spirit in Jesus name amen amen
we're going to talk about a time of
trouble up ahead
are we on the brink but this sounds like
a topic that is a recurring topic
but sooner or later it must reach a
culmination point
definitely and it's not going to be a
nice culmination point no but it is to
be expected
well you know the topic of the
abomination of desolation
that is standing in the Holy place is
one that is very irrelevant for the time
in which we are living
and let's look at some of the issues
that are you know coming to fruition
it's very important that we understand
that Babylon has three components as we
discussed in one of the lectures that we
had recently
and one of them is the false prophet
that aligns himself again with Babylon
and that is rather sad
because it costs a lot of blood and a
lot of energy
and a lot of study to bring about the
Reformation
and the Reformation
is dying
in fact it has already been declared
dead by some
well the Reformation can never be dead
but it can be reduced to a Remnant well
September the 21st 2015. that was the
year when the pope visited the United
States
it's interesting that all these things
happen always in September right
that's a month that needs to be watched
right it's it when I was putting the
slides in US it occurred to me yeah it's
interesting everything happening in
September yes well Christianity Today
reported then
from Antichrist to brother in Christ how
Protestant pastors view the Pope
and that's a very true statement
and how can they view the Pope on the
basis of an appearance
you know these people all practice
Jesuit theater
Hollywood they're all actors many of the
pubs were actually
physically actors and they all study
these things especially if they are
involved with Jesuit institutions
so you have to base it on Doctrine on
what they believe and not on now does he
have a pleasant smile or not and you
have a nice
talk yes or a nice white robe on
so how did that happen more than half of
Evangelical pastors say Pope Francis is
their brother in Christ that means more
than half
don't know that Christ doesn't exist in
their Doctrine as the one who paid the
price for you that's true if you take
this in the concept of the desolation of
the sanctuary
then that you cannot say he's a brother
in Christ you cannot he's not a brother
in Christ no it's the Antichrist because
he teaches another gospel
and if anyone comes says Paul and
preaches another Christ or another
gospel then have nothing to do with him
simple as that you cannot even negotiate
with him because how can you negotiate
between nothing and something dear
that's true
more than one-third say they value the
Pope's view on theology that is a
horrendous figure they should all be
horrified
they mustn't call themselves Protestant
they must then rather become Catholic
then they must become like Cardinal
Newman and Booker suite at the Vatican
now again let me reiterate we're not
against Catholics it's against the
theology that negates the ministry of
Jesus Christ in fact it negates is very
deity and that's important because we
again like you said we're not against
people no and persons it is against the
system and the doctrines yes
and I have no no animosity towards them
but I have great animosity towards their
Doctrine yeah because it's the opposite
of the Bible
and because I was trapped in it
what a relief to find the truth
you know if you don't study the inner
workings or doctrines of the
denomination you're in how will you know
what that actually stands for
in a war situation
if there's going to be a war do you
study the machinations of the enemy well
you have to you have to otherwise you're
going to
run into trouble right
so three intense say has improved their
view of the Catholic Church
those are amongst the findings of a new
study of a thousand Protestant senior
pastors released this week from
Nashville based LifeWay research well
Nashville is another one of those
interesting towns but let's not go there
overall the survey found that many
Protestant pastors have taken a liking
to Pope Francis nearly four in ten say
the pope known for his humility and
concern for the poor has had a positive
impact on their opinions of the Catholic
church almost two-thirds view Pope
Francis as genuine Christian and brother
in Christ
two-thirds
in other words they have not read table
talk
take it back to the 60s with Vatican II
I wonder how many what the ratio of the
Protestants accepting the Catholic
church then would have been they have
forgotten entirely what the Protestant
Reformation was about they haven't read
chiniki's book 50 years in the Church of
Rome
they haven't read Vatican assassins they
haven't read any of those things they
haven't read romanism and the
Reformation by gratan Guinness the the
Church of England view before the Oxford
movement
I haven't read any of it and also
if you take our spirit of Prophecy
quotes on Rome never changes
so you cannot look at him and think oh
but all those atrocities of those days
will not happen again it's impossible
for him to change without denying
infallibility impossible
2022 the National Catholic register
evangelicals are becoming more open to
the Catholic Church
it's a trend oh yeah
remember that video that we showed yeah
I think two years ago or longer where
that um Smith I can't remember his name
that's your name yes
oh that Pastor he prayed and he said I
believe that the Catholic Church of the
Protestant church are coming together
today and then we also showed Lou Ingle
yes they were kissing the feet of the
Evangelical Catholics unbelievable
so let's see what they have to say one
cause is the change in Generations
that is true
on the faculty and amongst the students
the newer younger ones just don't care
much about the differences because they
don't know history and because it's been
the goal of the Jesuits to get to this
and they don't know the doctrine of the
Roman Catholic Church
I grew up a Catholic
I'd never understood their doctrines
until I saw the opposite in the word of
God
all right so you can still find a good
bit of anti-catholic prejudice but it's
not partisan it doesn't include the
feeling that the Catholic church is the
enemy that must be vanquished to protect
the pure Gospel of Luther Calvin and
kranman
let's add Latimer and Ridley and
melankton and John Knox and Wesley and
you name them
another cause is evangelicals greater
experience of Catholic teachers and
writing writers they're swallowing
Catholic Doctrine and they've
infiltrated
thank you for finishing that sentence
because I was at the loss of words there
for a moment
some of the faculty had Catholic mentors
and they're not going to say that
someone to whom they owe so much was a
consort of the of Babylon
Martin
this is catholic's writing they know
exactly what protestantism you used to
believe and they're mocking it exactly
it's it's a slap in the face
this is
desecrating
everything making it desolate
that Jesus put down there was an
ecumenical movement
at which some
that believed in the great controversy
were present
and the Catholic priest got up and said
do you still believe according to that
book The Great controversy
that the Church of Rome is the of
Babylon
and the representative who knew about
the great controversy spluttered and
splattered and didn't know what to say
and afterwards lamented the fact that we
had such a horrible View
oh and I thought to myself
what he could have done it was such a
beautiful opportunity
there was a situation where the entire
Protestant and Catholic World were in
this setting
and he could have just said to them do
you still believe that
and then mentioned the doctrines of Rome
one after the other and if he affirms
them then say
you have answered your own question
thank you
that would have made a great impact
don't you think definitely that would
have made the type of impact that
reformers did when they were standing
before prelates and kings and queens now
they can be two reasons why he didn't do
it like that
the one is it was either indoctrinated
and caught up in the whole thing well
the other thing is it could have been
part of it you could have been part of
it either ignorance
or apostasy one of the two
so many of the students have had similar
friendships or a Catholic writer who has
meant a lot to them some have taken
advantage of Catholic Retreats or
spiritual Direction
yeah some of the pastors who are sitting
in economical councils love the
spiritual Retreats and the Jesuit
Retreats getting something from the
church their own tradition doesn't offer
them yes
in other words a gospel
that negates Christ but uses spiritual
formation experiential religion induced
through hypnosis
and they could have had another one here
being indoctrinated by Jesuit theater
correct yes
a third cause is how many are found in
Catholic teaching something they
couldn't find in evangelicalism
in my experience many involved in
culture and politics found themselves
turning to Catholic Social teachings
modern is that the Bible no
not at all so are they are they busy
with the gospel or are they busy with
social issues that's the thing like
we've shown that video a few times of
the Pope where he also said we have to
get together in Social so the Jew and
Christian or the Muslim everybody can
get together handing out food
that is not religion it is a consequence
of religion but it is not religion I
cannot sit and worship with someone who
denies the Divinity of Christ or the
messiahship of Christ
but I can play a game of whatever with
him and have a meal together with him
but worship with him never it's
impossible we have different gods
pro-life activists for example found a
moralistic vision of the issue in its
relationship to all the other issues
with a wiser way of understanding what
they're doing and why
those who'd begun the question free
market Orthodoxy found deeper
understanding of what economic freedom
meant
according to my understanding their
economic freedom is bondage yes
you will own nothing and you'll be happy
and you'll be quiet we're going back to
the Middle Ages and the church will
decide who owns something and who does
not and the church will draw the map
this belongs to Spain this belongs to
Portugal this belongs to me and this
belongs to me is one for you and five
for me and so we carry on yes thank you
very much
how far is this going
September the 5th 2022 Irish teacher
jailed after refusing to use transgender
pronouns
I will not give up my Christian beliefs
this is interesting Martin
it's actually scary also enochberg a
Christian and a teacher at Wilson's
Hospital Secondary School
in multifarnum Co westmeath which is a
church of Ireland school was arrested
on September 5 for contempt of court in
a case which had emerged from his
refusal to call a boy a girl
in the classroom
my religious beliefs are not misconduct
they are not gross misconduct he told
the court they never will be they are
dear to me I will never deny them and
never betray them and I will never bow
to an order that would require me to do
so it is just not possible for me to do
that now he has a point
I don't know how much knowledge she has
on the Plan of Salvation And The Gospel
and the teachings of Rome etc etc but on
this point he has a point yeah
he added that upholding the biological
reality of male and female could not
lead to a charge of gross misconduct and
such a charge was the only thing which
could lead to a suspension he was
sentenced to serve an unspecified jail
term
it's amazing I can't
you almost think this is not true this
is like the Inquisition exactly until
you recant
and you will sit in that Tower
until you light a candle
and tell us that you have recanted then
you can come out of jail okay
to last until he purges his contempt or
until further order of the court judge
Michael Quinn stated that he was
sentencing Burke to prison based only on
his contempt of court
not on his beliefs well I think that
judge is talking a lot of nonsense
exactly that's just twisting it to suit
the court all right so this is the
Inquisition using the court systems and
this might be a precursor of coming to
use your court soon yes now you know of
course that court is a game
you play on the tennis court
and you serve
there are all kinds of things that are
interesting in the English language uh
let's not go into those details or else
we'll be sidelined I just want to
mention one more you watch a channel on
television yes channeling so yeah and
you bring the ship to a birth and it's a
program
this is another thing
here's another article from September
the 15th 2022.
Jewish philosopher
the only four strong enough to stop woke
near Marxism is Christianity
amazing and we've had a couple of people
say in the past that we need Christian
values
and they come from Jewish people that
are saying these so the integration has
become so absolute
that the sanctuary really has been
trodden underfoot definitely
an Israeli philosopher has called on
conservatives in the U.S to appropriate
the only Force
that is capable of stopping the newly
emerged totalitarian woke neo-marxism
and that is biblical Christianity yet
this will require repentance at personal
communal and National levels
this is an appeal
to bring about what Revelation says will
happen in the United States yes that's
why we've shown it in the previous this
is aging ever so slightly oh actually
it's not aging anymore it's it's
starting to pick up pushing it's pushing
so an orthodox Jew resides in Jerusalem
has a knee is Chairman of the Edmund
Burke Foundation is responsible for the
netcon which has come under Fire in the
past for its tacit approval of
homosexuality and same-sex marriage
what God needs us to do is our part and
our part is to repent and the first part
of repentance is that Christians
Catholics Protestants Orthodox Orthodox
Jews cannot continue to sit on the
sidelines and allow the country to
continue in the direction that it's
going he explained and Christians in
general must have the courage to
publicly affirm this was a Christian
Nation historically and according to its
laws and it's going to be a Christian
Nation again is that an image to the
Beast definitely
it's going to be a Biblical Nation
is that prophecy yes so there has to be
biblical laws that we have a program
showing what they were saying and what
Jonathan Khan was saying and all of
these things
the Great Commission means that if you
are a Christian you are axiomatically a
Christian nationalist he concludes Oh I
thought the pope said that was a swear
word
and but he says it's okay because
Catholics and Christians and Orthodox
can stand together
we are in the Great pendulum swing
movement from absolute liberalism
to Absolute
draconianism under the Garb of biblical
Christianity you are quite right Martin
so this clash between conservativism
and liberalism
is going to culminate in a religious
situation and it can
possibly lead to a civil war yes even if
it remains on the ideological level
if the church was silent 20 years ago
well that was one thing but to say today
that well I don't want to be political
how can you not be political William
Wilberforce about whom I've written and
I mentioned in the book along with
Bonhoeffer he was dealing with the
slavery issue in the slave trade he knew
it was satanic and he was political in
saying we've got to do what we can
because we're Christians and when people
say but you're being political he would
say no I'm simply doing what God
commands me to do to be a voice for the
voiceless the African slaves don't have
a voice if I don't speak God will judge
me if I don't speak for The Unborn today
God will judge me Eric what specifically
then do Christians need to do do we need
to attend school board meetings run for
office I mean Beyond just speaking up
what should we do well we need to do
everything in other words I think that
if if when we talk about the church
we're talking about multiplied millions
of Americans uh who each has a different
calling so we just have to ask God lord
what would you have me to do but
do something we had pulpits uh on fire
uh before the Revolution advocating
against tyranny they weren't afraid to
be political
so he says it must become political
and it seems the church leaders agree
with him
so we're going to get an image of the
Beast even if it takes a civil war
so even in 2021 in December ex-army
generals fear Insurrection or Civil War
in 2024 that's the next election not and
it's really building it's really
building I mean look at the
um
clips that we've looked at previously
yes
so three retired U.S army generals have
warned of insurrection or possibly even
Civil War the results of the 2024
presidential election are not accepted
by sections of the military
oh we don't have to know who they all
are they warned of the potential of
total breakdown of the chain of command
along partisan lines
and the risk of a shadow government led
by a losing candidate who refuses to
concede defeat directly referencing
former president Donald Trump in short
we are chilled to our bones at the
thought of a coup succeeding next time
and ideological battle lines are
definitely being drawn I mean if you
just look at everything the FBI raid and
this talk of Civil War by the media
brainwashing everybody already for this
and then we've got that statement from
the spirit of Prophecy yes
well here we have a clip from EWTN which
is a Catholic news agency
and let's see what they are discussing
with their Protestant colleagues
joining us now from Rome is David
Hathaway A Protestant pastor and
president of the Eurovision mission to
Europe after the Russian invasion of
Ukraine in 2014 I was able to call all
the Christian denominations together
and and that's a miracle because I had
Catholic
I had Orthodox I had all the
evangelicals the Pentecostal the
charismatic every single denomination
and I asked some one question
I said look we can work together in
prayer if we forget all religious
doctrines and if you will accept only
two things one the only Authority in the
church is the Bible and secondly the
only salvation is in the name of Jesus
they all agreed and for six years we had
prayer meetings with ten thousand people
and the interesting thing is that the
people who were praying leading the
prayers were the heads of every single
denomination on the platform
so Martin if you set aside the doctrine
then there's no problem
and that's what we've been saying all
along
there has to be a compromise there has
to be a compromise
but uh
what about the Bible that says take heed
of the doctrine
that's a problem right it is so the
compromise is only possible on the basis
of ignoring
any doctrine that is contrary to this
Union
and I've also got the problem
all the denominations the Catholics and
all of them coming together and he said
you must acknowledge that the Bible is
the standard but he didn't say which
Bible
yes and do they still know their Bible
or have they become confused by
swallowing
jesuitical counter-reformation theology
like futurism
exactly for instance if you have the do
a Rhymes Bible and I say okay that's
perfect I'll go according to that one
and Mary then Mary crushes the head yeah
you've got a big problem so you can go
ahead but you don't have the same Jesus
or the same Bible correct
so Martin the pendulum is going to swing
as we saw back to a religious viewpoint
and politics is going to become evolved
and nationalism Christian nationalism
will again take Center Stage that's what
it seems like
the denominations will all be together
by discarding any doctrine that
separates them and therefore uniting on
points that they have in common and that
would be Sunday and spiritualism namely
the immortality of the Soul they have
those doctrines in common
so if somebody is talking to a long-lost
grandfather
or to Eleanor Roosevelt or anyone else
then that's acceptable it's fine because
then the dead know everything even
though the Bible says they know nothing
see and see in that situation even the
Indian that talks to the forefathers is
also okay
yes now this entire thing what what does
the Catholic do doesn't he talk to the
forefathers when he worships uh at the
feet of the Saints
so the various events in Italy now for
example are fascinating and it's
interesting how the left reacts to what
is happening in Italy now on the one
hand one is inclined to say well At Last
they're coming to their senses
but this is so dangerous
because if you know biblical prophecy
then you know
Christian values
that are based on the exclusion of right
doctrines
are more dangerous than liberalism
exactly because they will be persecution
from those Christians and why is it more
dangerous because it's harder to
recognize the error definitely
so here's a clip of the new leader in
Italy of what she said in the past and
what she's saying in the present foreign
grazia
everything we stand for is under attack
our individual freedom is under attack
our rights are under attack the
sovereignty of our nation is under
attack the prosperity and well-being of
our families under attack the education
of our children is under attack in front
of this people understand that in this
age the only way of being Rebels is to
preserve what we are the only way of
being Rebels is to be conservatives
only a few months ago
European Union bureaucrats wrote a
document hundreds of pages long
telling us that in order to be inclusive
we had to exclude all references to
Christmas
Jesus Mary and all Christian names were
to be removed from all official
communication will we surrender in front
of this
no we will not we will fight it we will
fight it Standing Tall
[Applause]
well that was a rousing speech
and there are many in the United States
that believe the same yes and there are
many on the left that are horrified that
something like this could happen so
let's listen to The Counter discussions
that exist
start today by talking about a
politician on the right who we should
all be worried about who's on the rise
today a politician who has brushed off
accusations of fascism what separates us
from let's say
Italy who elected a a fascist she is
from fascist Roots the far-right
political party whose roots go back to
post World War II neo-fascists a party
that has its roots in Italian fascism
they said it could never happen again
100 years ago Mussolini marching on Rome
plunging the country into two decades of
dictatorship an alliance with Hitler in
a second world war today the fascist
party is gone but many say these are
their political heirs the brothers of
Italy once on the fringes they've
ballooned into the biggest party in the
country now their leader Georgia Maloney
is poised to head the most hard-right
government since ilduche the 45 year old
Firebrand insists she's no fascist just
a proud conservative and nationalist
comfortable nevertheless with some of
the Hallmarks of Italian fascism like
this motto
God Fatherland and family
by the way Martin they have just
demonstrated that they don't have a clue
as to what fascism really is Right
correct they don't know the definitions
and Faith Fatherland and family has got
nothing to do with fascism fascism is
government and Industry and partnership
for community and that is exactly what
the world in the liberal forums is
practicing today
and even if they swing to the
conservative forums they are still
practicing it so the world is fascist at
the moment but they are branding fascism
as something totally different they are
being led by the nose and remember a
while back they compare Trump with
Mussolini yes and now they compare her
also with Mussolini so everything it's
amazing how they left
is portraying the right as this fascist
and they got the definition totally
wrong yes so they are denigrating
fascism by introducing it
now how far is this conservativism going
is it just Italy or is it a wave let's
listen to this man who had a meeting in
Australia and came up with the same sort
of battle
so let's talk about whether the right
whether they're dying out I mean what is
happening here because no look at Italy
Georgia Maloney is going to become the
Italian Prime Minister look at Sweden
two weeks ago that country ruled by
social Democrats since 1945 until now
there's going to be a conservative
majority leading Sweden actually all
over the world you know we are seeing a
move against globalism because what's
globalism done it's made the rich richer
and disadvantaged absolutely everybody
else but somehow somehow in our
countries we get people who masquerade
at election time as being conservatives
don't have the courage to stand up and
fight for our values they're desperate
for leadership in Australia and they
don't see where it's coming from but
also they feel and quite rightly so that
it's an assault on all fronts that what
was status quo yesterday is far right
today
well basically the point that he is
making is that this wave is beginning to
flow not only over one country but
numerous countries right pendulum
pendulum swing
now you need another few things to
happen so that you can have the pendulum
swing a good depression
might just facilitate things
is Asia Market September 27 2022 new
Great Depression likely in 2023
Life as we know it is about to change
dramatically as the world is plunged
into a far-reaching economic depression
that's the view of Veteran analyst
Francis Hunt who believes Central Bank
overreach and Global debt will create an
environment the world has never seen
before unlike the Great Depression of
the 1930s this will be a full-scale
globalized depression and told Asia
markets it's pretty dystopian message
we're seeing it across all charts it's
going to be brutal on any form of
Leverage and it's going to be an
impoverishing event generally for the
middle classes
we've said all along that the model that
they want is a return to the model of
the Middle Ages where you had the elites
and you had the church and then you had
the serfs
and that is where we are heading the
middle class has to go and the way you
do that is you implode the markets
this is Epoch times also
very recent Morgan Stanley warns of
something worse than a normal recession
so chief U.S Equity strategist Michael
Wilson said that he's convinced the
corporate earnings recession is coming
and that it could be worse than a normal
recession we think it's unavoidable
to avoid an earnings recession and
that's what matters for stocks Williams
said with his remarks coming on the same
day that the so-called Wall Street fear
gauge soared to its highest level since
mid-june when U.S equities last hit a
bear Market bottom so basically the
world is being told we're heading for a
time of trouble that's it like the
previous article actually stated it like
that
now we've got to add some wall back into
the mix and some reactions and some
economic strategies linked to wall
strategies and then you've got all these
problems you know you've just mentioned
the financial system crashing
going back to the Dark Ages well we're
literally going back to dark with no
electricity or energy somebody is going
to switch the lights off it looks like
it somebody made a joke and said they
met the Prince of Darkness and they
thought he was the CEO of the electric
company
laughs
so mail online Ukraine accuses Russia of
North stream terror attack as gas leaks
from sabotaged pipelines sent vast rings
of churning bubbles up to 3 000 feet
wide to Baltic Sea servers following an
undersea explosions
and here is the picture of what is
happening
so a military statement claimed that the
largest leak is spreading bubbles a good
kilometer
in diameter the smallest is creating a
circle about 200 meters in diameter
while the head of Denmark's energy
agency said it could take up to a week
for gas to stop draining into the sea so
the sea surface is full of methane which
means there's an increased risk of
explosions in the sea in the area
and he added that ships could lose
buoyancy if they entered the affected
region
the unsettling incident comes as
Sweden's National seismology Center
announced that their equipment
registered a powerful undersea blasts in
the region yesterday
it said one explosion was equivalent to
a magnitude 2.3 earthquake
so they're blowing up the pipelines hmm
well well let's see European Gas Prices
rose on the news of the leaks with the
Benchmark October Dutch price up almost
10 percent on Tuesday prices are still
below this year's stratopheric Peaks but
remain more than 200 percent higher than
in early September 2021.
so imagine if they sabotage those
pipelines
then the gas situation in Europe will
look pretty bleak definitely because I
don't think it's going to take a week to
repair this and you're entering winter
now
it's an interesting Blame Game there
yeah that is where it's getting really
interesting here Ukraine is accusing
Russia okay Ukraine is recusing Russia
and Russia is accusing the waste well
does it makes you know what if it's a
double blind then I can see Russia doing
it maybe it's planned you see but if
it's not why would they if it's a if
it's a god it will it's no economic
privilege for them to blow up their own
pipelines well let's have a look
what did Biden say some time ago on the
issue
if Russia invades that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the border of
Ukraine again then there will be uh we
there will be no longer on North stream
too if we we will bring it into it
how will you do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's control
we will I promise you we'll be able to
do it
with regard to Nordstrom too
we continue to have a very strong and
clear conversations with our German
allies and I want to be clear with you
today if Russia invades Ukraine one way
or another nordstream 2 will not move
forward as you all know these pipelines
weren't pumping gas into Europe at this
time ns2 was never operational as you
guys know ns1 has not been operational
for weeks because Putin has weaponized
energy and we have said this many times
before
just drives home the importance of our
efforts to work together to get
alternative gas supplies to Europe and
to support efforts to reduce gas
consumption and accelerate true energy
independence by moving to clean energy
economy
is there a possibility that they could
sabotage their own livelihood for the
sake of an agenda Martin I think so
because the end justifies the means ah
now there's a problem here don't stop
talking like a Jesuit
foreign
there's one thing that's bothering me
she says that that gas pipe has been
turned off Now where's the bubbles
coming from
well must be going from what's left in
the pipe right
it can only take a little while for
still to come out but now it's blown up
it seems well let's just go back in
history to The Economist in 2019 and
they had this interesting collage over
here of what was going to happen in the
future the rise of China for example
they had you know this image over here
that comes back all the way from
Leonardo da Vinci he has an interesting
plant in his hand over here which we
won't go into details he has DNA on his
on his forearm and all of these
interesting things they even had the
South African election down here in it
and they had Putin over here and closely
associated with them you had the writers
of the Apocalypse
so in 2019 were they planning some form
of Apocalypse this is pre
pandemic yes we actually remember we had
a episode where we discussed this this
even the phone with a QR code on and all
of this yes we discussed that but we
didn't know we more about the Putin side
yes now here if we enlarge this little
section on Putin there's certain writing
there that's written in reverse and I
think at that stage we also said that
writing in Reverse is an occult
principle
Alice the Crowley taught the people to
write backwards walk backwards talk
backwards all of those things that's why
Beatles and all all of them recorded if
you play their records backwards there's
actually meaning yes yes there's a
there's a subliminal there and of course
they have Pinocchio and his his nose is
relatively long which means everything's
based on lies
but then they have Putin they have the
apocalypse Associated directly with him
and we also discussed that then and
there was a reverse there but never mind
but the writing over here is very
interesting in Reverse Putin's Pipelines
plural
what does that mean that they're going
to blow them up
well to bring about a time of trouble
such as never was
button we're living in interesting times
let's say
that that is for sure
the Bible says a time of trouble such as
never was economically
environmentally
they're certainly helping with that oh
definitely they have to reset build back
better destroy what there was so that
out of the ashes they can rise again now
remember that relief that you have in
the United Nations
where the Phoenix Rises out of the ashes
of a destroyed Humanity
and uh
I have news for that phonics
because that phonics represents Satan is
going to be locked up in the bottomless
pit when the Lord Jesus comes there will
be a symbolic chain that binds him
because he won't have anything to do
except look that he is destroyed world
the build back better will get to the
destruction stage but not to the
building backstage
and we are I believe at this point in
history and may God help us to open our
eyes
and to realize where we are in the
Stream of time with regard to the
Abomination that causes desolation let's
pray
Heavenly Father
history written in advance
in the word of God
doctrines explaining the Plan of
Salvation
expounded by authors and Prophets
and all of it being laid aside for the
sake of unity
help us to cling
to it is written
is my prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign